[Music]
start with the one secret audio
recording heard round the newsroom's
hall around the country conspiracy TV
MSNBC and CNN and all the likes of them
private conversation recorded between
Michael Cohen and his client Donald
Trump last night it was released bicones
attorney Lanny Davis in spite of all the
breathlessness in the reporting the tape
is a ambiguous kind of hard to hear
reveals no groundbreaking new
information let's just play it for you
our selves I need to open up a company
for the transfer of all of that info
regarding our friend David you know so
that I'm gonna do that right away I've
actually come up a lot to me and I've
spoken to Alan why superb about how to
set the whole thing up with funding that
yes and it's all the stuff all the stuff
because here you never know where that
company never know where he's gonna hit
he gets it correct so I'm all over that
and I spoke to Alan about it when it
comes time for the financing which will
be you listen what phase what have to do
so what you just heard amounts to
nothing it never happened the contents
of that tape provides literally no new
information zero zero significance here
no criminal law in question and what you
just witnessed is something that occurs
every single day at every major company
in the country crisis management to
protect a brand's image and reputation
in this case it's the Trump Organization
but over on the destroyed Trump media
this was once again a daily
earth-shattering scandal that's gonna
bring down the president except it's not
take a look we now have a secret audio
recording that apparently shows Donald
Trump discussing payments to bury a
story about an alleged affair with a
Playboy Playmate oh the timing here is
ever
the payments were discussed just before
he won the election think about that
there may be other issues here there may
be bank fraud tax fraud money laundering
issues with the way they structured the
payments those kinds of issues in the
end could be more dangerous and damaging
than the campaign finance issue I think
it's a very embarrassing and humiliating
take for the president and I think
ironically Giuliani says I can I can
understand what's on this tape because
I've listened to mob tapes you know what
the president is similar to a mob tape
if you listen to this again it sounds
like this is the weekly or the monthly
Michaels here to figure out what we have
to cover up meeting now these are the
same people now who literally peddle day
after day crisis after crisis it's like
24/7 the same people were pushing
impeachment even before the president
took office the same people who were
predicting the end of days or at least
the end of Trump
ever since he descended from that
escalator in Trump Tower in 2015 and
announced his candidacy to be the
president the same people who have
literally gone through three major
crises this week alone now in order to
show you how the mainstream corrupt
media has literally turned into a
real-life version of Chicken Little we
put together what's we're calling a mega
montage of some of the worst moments but
get ready because the sky is falling
every second of the day watch you better
be ready for the fact that he might be
leading the Republican ticket I
understand why so many people voted for
him I understand where you were coming
from I understand why you liked him but
this man is lying to you Donald Trump is
a president with whom there is grave
question about his fitness and ability
to conduct the office of the president's
I'll say it again this Russian
connection just keeps building and every
time it builds and expands you have to
wonder if Trump himself isn't worried
about what's swirling around under the
covers the entire world's watching and
of course most importantly Vladimir
Putin's watching it seemed like
yesterday was his love
no to Vladimir Putin it is certainly an
unusual speech a weird speech Rocketman
insulting kim jung-han yes i have
thought an awful lot about blowing up
the white house of course I want to
punch him in the face
16 tweets today to start the new year
some of them deeply disturbing these are
the messages from a person who is not
well said he's an excellent help but I
mean Sanjay Gupta came out was like not
so sure about excellent health President
Trump is goading Kim jong-un to test a
nuclear missile again to prove its
reliability to show him wrong
the stormy saga takes a dramatic turn as
the porn star speaks out on her alleged
affair with citizen Trump stormy Daniel
Stravaganza you haven't heard from him
about the stormy Daniels guess he's a
polar is there a difference if the
president said whole-house I want to
read the definition of treason this was
nothing short of treasonous the idea
that the president would be revoking
security clearance not based on
wrongdoing just based on words it's
shameful with any previous president if
you'd woken up to this all-caps tweet
threatening war with iran you think he
probably belongs in a padded cell but
with trump this is kind of business as
normal just a tiny sampling this is
literally now every minute every hour of
every day
the media their friends on the left
three years of running obsessing over
the crisis of the second totally
ignoring the biggest issues that we the
people are facing in this country and
ignoring the massive success out of the
Trump administration and that they can't
weaponize the story against President
Trump they don't really seem interested
at all in covering it news is not
existing in this country on these
so-called news channels right here on
this show we have been sounding the
alarm about the serious corruption real
corruption real abuse of power a real
Russia scandal at the highest levels of
the DOJ and the FBI over at the destroy
Trump media crickets now naturally the
media goes to great lengths to avoid
talking about all the
positive developments surrounding the
country and the Trump administration
they won't want you to know about the
huge successes out of the White House
for the first time in years
we'll find out Friday America's GDP is
seeing healthy real growth remember was
just a short time ago the Obama
administration wanted Americans to
accept our so-called new normal like
Jimmy Carter saying wear a sweater a
pathetic growth rate of one or two
percent now according to projections our
second quarter growth should be about
four percent maybe higher add to that we
now have historic job growth two million
fewer people on food stamps there were
more jobs available than there are
people on unemployment in the country
and oh by the way the greatest labor
participation rate in history Wow
good news for the Forgotten men and
women the ones that voted for President
Trump even though the fix was in for
Hillary and of course they covered up
her crimes and then they turned their
sights on Trump and they even lied to
FISA Court judges a massive
accomplishment that you never hear about
and yesterday the president tweeted this
out our country is doing great best
financial numbers on the planet great to
have the USA winning again and on Friday
we expect that full GDP report for the
second quarter we'll bring you those
numbers as they become available but
tonight we have even more positive
developments that you'll never hear in
the media on the economic front after
months of negotiations and
fear-mongering by the media
oh he's starting a trade war well the
president put fears of that war with
Europe to rest as he signed off on a
significantly improved trade deal for
American businesses free of tariffs
barriers and subsidies here's the
president explaining all of this earlier
today let's take a look we agreed today
first of all to work together toward
zero tariffs zero non-tariff barriers
and zero subsidies on non auto
industrial goods thank you we will also
work to reduce barriers and increase
trade and services chemicals
pharmaceuticals medical products as well
as
soybeans soybeans is a big deal this
will open markets for farmers and
workers increase investment and lead to
greater prosperity in both the United
States and the European Union it will
also make trade fairer and more
reciprocal my favorite word reciprocal
well if we didn't negotiate that
wouldn't have happened and the president
pointed out today this deal will open
markets for farmers in America workers
increase investment lead to greater
prosperity in both the US and the
European Union win-win also make trade
fairer and more reciprocal as favorite
word as he said great news for goods
services made right here in the United
States good for the American worker that
was unemployed in the Obama years now
despite the constant negativity coming
from so much of the media and Democrats
you think they want the economy to grow
and be prosperous no they want their
power back more and more Americans
you're seeing the truth with your own
eyes we got a new poll out today in
spite of all the media hysteria oh look
at the hills poll the president's
approval rating is now higher than ever
nearly 50 percent oh by the way same
with Gallup same with NBC Wall Street
Journal and on the world stage the
president has also seen progress which
is good for our kids and grandkids the
president's pick I think an excellent
choice Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
hit the ground running he's overseeing
steady significant progress out of North
Korea China and yeah we're being tougher
on Russia than Obama ever dreamed of
because he was sending messages tell
Vladimir allow more flexibility after
the election well today the Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo he testified on the
hill and he explained to some of these
dumb senators that the president's peace
through strength strategy to counter the
hostile actions of Vladimir Putin and
the hostile regime of Russia and what
we're doing about it take a look the
United States calls on Russia to respect
the principles to which it has long
claimed to adhere and to end its
occupation of Crimea
end of quote I want to sure this
committee that the United States does
not will not recognize the Kremlin's
purported annexation of Crimea
we stand together with allies partners
and the international community in our
commitment to Ukraine and its
territorial integrity
there will be no relief of Crimea
related sanctions until Russia returns
control of the Crimean Peninsula to
Ukraine this Crimea declaration
formalizes United States policy of
non-recognition formalizes oh but but I
think there was somebody at NBC it
actually suggested that the president
was an agent of Russia this is how
insane so-called news is god now the
Secretary of State also helped
Democratic senators that aren't really
too bright some of them understand how
under the leadership of the president
the u.s. is actually leading from the
front all over the world not from behind
and we're not going on apology tours and
we're not dropping a hundred and fifty
billion dollars on the tarmac in cash
and other currency to the mullahs of
Iran that chant death to Israel and
death to America
take a look did he live hell Putin that
our release or ultimately relaxed
sanctions senator what you need to
conduct your role your appropriate wall
I will provide you today that is United
States policy with respect to the issues
you request you asked me about US policy
with respect to sanctions and I can
confirm to that no commitment has been
made to change those policies in any way
just just so the facts are clear the
previous administration is the one that
enabled Russia to have the capacity that
they have in Syria today I'm not
defending the previous administration
secretary I want this administration to
continue doing what's working its policy
this administration's policy you're
advocating for the continuation of this
administration's laws I think that's
important for everyone to understand
North Korea still has chemical and
biological weapons and brutalizes its
own people and again there's no
verifiable evidence that North Korea is
deep nuclearization senator we employ so
I am afraid that at this point the
United States the Trump administration
is being taken for a ride
fear not senator fear not there's no
evidence to there under or not senator
there's no evidence senator
hey please I guess you didn't ask a
questions all no that's all right please
fear not this administration has taken
enormous ly constructive actions that
have put us in a place that is far
better than in either of the two
previous administrations one Republican
one Democrat we have put sanctions
regime in place that is unequaled we are
continuing to enforce that sanctions
regime no missiles fired over Japan
dismantled nuclear test site hostages
turned home will have the bodies of
Americans killed in that war sent back
and we're talking about denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula and no bribery
now last but definitely not least
tonight some major breaking news out of
the deep State this is important moments
ago group of eleven House Republicans
have officially now introduced articles
of impeachment against the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosen Stein the guy
that signed the last FISA warrant after
months of obstructing what is
congressional subpoenas and failing to
comply with these subpoenas and
inhibiting the important investigation
and the FISA abuse the Russia witch-hunt
and so much more rod Rosenstein must now
be held accountable is called
congressional Government Oversight
it's called checks and balances co-equal
branches of government and yes the
United States Constitution and it's time
for rod Rosen Stein to be held
accountable